has anyone ever taken a shower that
makes you just
think differently about your life
choices i think that's everything you
need to change your shampoo if that's
that was today i was like i felt like
we're gonna be okay
i took a shower and i was like
everything's gonna be okay
alana is that not you you don't you
don't mike i feel like that was that was
him today just like he was
i clearly did not shower today no
again house broken in showers we're
working you remember your last shower
austin
it has changed since quarantine like
coveted definitely has like
they become like a little bit more of a
ah damn it everyone can do their
what i love is that this hides my my
headphones pretty if
pretty effectively no it doesn't yeah it
creates the magic illusion
i like that literally you're wearing a
hat with uh you're wearing a cap
you could just turn that cuff around no
it doesn't count it's not as cool as
this
literally
yeah he doesn't have a hoodie but he has
a bear idea bye he has a stunt
beret that's amazing no no no no no what
do you call this thing this is a bear
this is a very honest it's like a flat
cap
if you're in canada right who calls them
i don't know but it's always offended me
that americans just call them hats
if i'm wearing a beanie no it's nice and
american will be like nice hat and i'll
be like
hat no that's not a hat that person is
more of a head sock
that means he got dropped in fairness
jews have been told that for hundreds of
years
about their about their little actually
this is just the reminder of the divine
presence that's
the dodgers um this is the dodgers
yarmulke
uh outside of austin getting a dog which
i will have you all know was
very exciting for me um because i feel
like i've been hearing about this for
months
mostly from angela rather than austin
yeah about his independent
dog this is all new to me well i mean
it's probably not months but we were we
were vetting a bunch of different dogs
she's also been telling it to me in so
far as like when we get a dog you should
come hang out
which means i feel like i got a dog this
week
wait a minute it's like an arms it's
like you get all of the fun of a family
of the child but not that you can walk
away leave the child there
no i think we're grooming you as a dog
sitter uh
you gotta pick a better dog sitter
because alana does not live close you
wanna
you by the way you you are like five
minutes i don't even know that place is
open right now but
but but trying to choose a dog sitter
that's like 45 minutes away from you
can you not rain on my parade no no no
no no no
i'm just thinking you go to yeah i could
go
so isn't la traffic like really down
right now she could probably get there
in 20 minutes like it's
it's maybe yeah i mean yeah i actually
haven't driven further than a few miles
in like six months i'm trying to think
the farthest i
i've gone i've there have been really
really short runs
not there's been more than two occasions
but there was one shoot that i was
i was actually able to go to a
location and shoot for a week and a half
um that was cool but it was like crazy
cover completely like we all had to do
like the entire cast and crew including
the director had to show up to do
a covet test we waited in our car we got
the test immediately
like 15 minutes later then we all uh
had to do two tests typically a day the
medic would text
or would would check you as soon as you
got in and then
every there was like flow of traffic if
you wanted to get i think we talked
about this before if you want to get
crafty to text
somebody to get you something um and
then i just went to a studio
um on the west side
that every the new like client services
is covered compliant so they're like
there's a badass uv lamp that as soon as
somebody leaves we just blast it
um with everything everything bring your
own headphones
there's no more paper scripts typically
i'll bring my ipad or they have one
there for me
um obviously no clients are there so
there's like there's you're typically
just there with an engineer
you never even come into contact with
anybody else you just kind of wave high
through the glass
uh you do your session and and you leave
so
it's it's a weird new normal
but it's the thing that i have enjoyed
is that i've been able to like
get in my car and drive um
i picked up this audiobook that i kind
of like had pressed pause on for a while
so
but yeah you're right yeah it's by and
large like my i have to get a new car in
january
and i'm like well i mean i'm not really
gonna yeah
i'm not gonna go the austin route i'm
not going to be like no car
for a year and a half is it 18 months
how long did you not have a car i
haven't had it
for two years two years it was it was
one of those that i
i was in this minor fender bender that
uh because my car was about 10 years old
it hit just the right way there were no
ways you hit a 15 year old
[Laughter]
it was a minor minor they made very
little
they made very little dent on the car uh
there's a man in the coal industry that
you hit
no but it was one of those technical
totals you know where um
where the damage it barely looked like
especially because the car was black you
couldn't even really see that much but
when they
pulled off the bumper the frame was all
bent and they said you know this is a
the repair cost is estimated to be 95
percent the value of the car
wow um because it was uh you know it was
a
10 year old prius and it was like you
know i don't know
i think both numbers were like around 10
grand and so they were like
just here's a check you know go get a
new car
and i was like or or i just don't get a
car
and i did the math on like if i were to
replace this with a comparable
car and let's say i were to you know
like i worked out a bunch of different
models of like car payments leases and
whatnot
and doing the math it was like um
using i could use uber
or lyft or whatever like 10 times a day
and still save money and that's what it
was for me
i also didn't need it yeah but that
doesn't
necessarily apply in all instances
sometimes i rent a car or whatever but
during covert because even car rentals
have been
personalists uh i keep getting rejected
because
they won't take my passport so yeah so i
if i've needed to go somewhere far
i've had to have someone take me like so
what does that look like
do you have to have an international
driver's license or what is it i have no
idea
by the way the ulti get new driver's
license is the biggest pain in the ass
oh yeah what is that that it's like
there's a new type of
a real quote real id yeah i saw this at
the airport i think
uh once months ago and i thought ah if i
don't pay attention to that it probably
won't
it won't buy by october so like today
yep well i need to get one anyway but
i've been avoiding the dmv especially
right now
um but yeah no you can generally drive
on an international license
uh there are some restrictions but
um i've been able to drive on my
australian international license this
whole time legally so it's not a problem
but it's just an issue where paperwork
is concerned where processing is
concerned
so it's like a problem whether if i need
to get i can't order alcohol so
i don't drink at all which i don't want
to alone anyway
but i can't order alcohol from anyone
because these digital services won't
accept
my uh ids so even like drizzly not not
to give them a plug but none of them
those those people give zero [ __ ] the
only time
i ordered it from a 7-eleven and uh the
guy like i was like
here i don't know if this will work but
i really hope it does because it was for
a fun house stream where we had to drink
and he ended up just being like
i'll just use my id i was like i can see
your passport i could
i could see your i have the same
reaction i'm just gonna
be like you shouldn't give me that
answer
that's i was very happy about it but it
turns out he was 17
also what about like yeah australia
but this one's fake anyway can i come in
for a drink actually
yeah what about what about like ordering
weed like like can you can you use your
passport for that
never tried i have no idea i know that i
can tell you uh
um uh we a couple of
months no no no this is this would have
been pre-covet i guess um
so early earlier this year i guess we
went down to
san diego and met with our our dear uh
friend from ready dawn andrea pasino who
was
uh participating in a uh what was bill
turned out to be a bunch of [ __ ] and it
was lame and he bailed but it was like
supposed to be this sort of intense
friends trivia competition and he's like
no one can touch me
so we thought it'd be a funny
juxtaposition you have to put up a
picture of andrea
for for people to understand i know this
is not the person
that's gonna know he's an anomaly yeah
you should not know about
what are the characters names veronica
and
yeah conservatory trained uh uh musician
and uh coder matt and he's the he's the
yeah the cto
uh of ready at dawn and like
isn't he also is wasn't he also like an
opera singer like can he not like is he
not a singer probably
i know he's a big opera fan i don't know
if he he can but he's
he's just he's too cool he's like 50
things but then he also
he also was a competitively like
national
achievement level pinball player uh it's
hilarious he's a gr
incredible selection of analog sense
like he's a west coast
like moog yeah guy yeah big junkie but
wait a minute wait oh i can do this
joey yep that's terrible
you can do this you definitely could do
that phoebe phoebe
thank you uh monica no i can't do it
kramer no oh my god
monica i'll make sure that he never sees
this ah
what was david schwimmer uh um jennifer
anderson's character's name
is [ __ ] it was literally a hairstyle in
the 90s
yeah the uh was it the jennifer
oh hell yeah yeah everyone can do right
now her name is was the name of the
haircut
i feel like jennifer anderson has had
the same haircut forever and it looks
incredible
yeah it was she gave the layers i'll
give you a clue the hairstyle was called
the rachel rachel
mike david schwimmer's character's name
uh uh rachel and
alex jones what's his name oh my god
he's lost with ross and chandler ross
and chandler
there
yeah i think that this the whole reason
i even brought that up was because
uh they did it we drove down to san
diego to cheer him on for this thing and
just to hang out and then
the bar wouldn't let us in because they
they said angela's uh costa rican
both passport and um
uh her like id kind of equivalent of a
driver's license basically but also
costa rican
they wouldn't take them um and they were
like
uh county law says it's got to be a a
u.s license um yeah so we literally
that's interesting or city law or some
one of those that it was one of those
that was local to that area and the bar
was you know
take two kind of year kind of around
it was so annoying we drive like two and
a half hours and then we get down there
and they look and they go oh wow cool
costa rica nah
see ya massive bummer yeah i'm okay in
la
and okay in austin which is the two that
i really need to use it for but i would
love to go get a get a license like it
is definitely a thing that i need to do
but especially right now i don't feel
like i want to go to a dmv
like i'm just like forever i'll
yeah ever there's there's a few that you
can go to
even the zootopia one well yeah
but there's also the one where it's
almost like the the old night in
uh the last crusade was like i knew you
would come
um he's been guarding his station for
you know forever for somebody can you
just do the rest of this in that voice
today
that brought me chose poorly
i was drinking a oh so i got i got an
espresso machine
i'm very excited you coffee buddy i
guess someone's doing good i guess
someone got a lot of wish lists and uh
this was um i get i get i get the beans
from my local coffee shop which is
awesome
down the road um and i uh
what did i do oh i then ruin it by
putting in um
uh biscoth syrup
which is
it's amazing that sounds amazing i
didn't know that existed it is amazing
it's it's um it's what what's the name
of the the chemical that gives biscoff
its flavors
bachelors i don't know something
speculative oh my god you can buy this
online
you can get biscuit cookie butter spritz
mike why haven't i never been told about
this we were keeping this from the only
mistake i made was i bought it in a rush
like midnight there's so much stuff but
i bought a bottle and i accidentally
saw it out of the australian size bottle
of this i'm gonna get it for you because
oh my god biscoff's like crack
joey monica
absolutely incredible um i guess like
now i should just do the intro of the
show
you know we've really covered a lot of
bases here oh i've got the ceremony too
much just drink take a shot right now
that's incredible i i love those
biscuits
speculoos
very like you know brave new world
uh exactly i don't feel anything anymore
yeah okay okay well now i'm sort of
disgusted he's just drinking the cereal
all right well this took two seconds ago
you were you were the happiest
like child like wonder my dog
you can't just shot syrup but i will
take the ice cream
that's absolutely amazing yeah that
mixed with stuff is lovely
on its own it's an experience it's
terrible
i like a vanilla latte and if you just
have the vanilla syrup it's disgusting
and tastes like alcohol it's not
none of it is good oh really i've never
tried my damn hair but i had
that and it was horrible thank you hi
everyone welcome to play watch listen
i'm alana i am joined by austin wintery
he is a video game composer troy baker
who is a video game actor and mike
bithell
who is a video game shots of syrup syrup
money bags [ __ ] money bags haiku is a
wishlist advocate
yeah i wanted to ask i do i like a wish
list i like you
you've been amazingly subtle about it
online lately
i'm playing it very low-key yeah i'm not
pushing it you know
too hard no don't be afraid to tell
people about it subtle marketing you can
never get what you want if you don't
tell people about it so
you know we've got to be careful about
that but i did want to ask like you so
you've now
sound sent out some codes for the video
game
which you have made during quarantine um
that is coming out next week i was very
intent on playing it before
we recorded today and i just ran out of
time i'm glad i'm sorry
i'm not my intent then i would have felt
it wow
troy played it i hated it it's it's no i
i and i told you this i texted you this
i literally just want to play the game
so i can troll greg that's all i want
yeah like i
like him you know what do you know
what's crazy is he's really good in it
like it's going to annoy you oh i know
it really like no i really did a good
job look
i am a fan of greg miller i i think that
greg is
and i also i would love to see greg uh i
like greg in a performance capacity
i like him preferably when he has a
shirt on
well he's good with the shirt he's good
with the shirt he's good with the shirt
he uses this shirt
he uses the show yeah that's his actual
character yeah
that's a little bit outside in but
whatever um but i just want to i just
want to
make him go to bed every night and go i
did
i did good right that ain't good he did
but i don't like trolling them hard and
be like hey man you made some strong
choices
you were you were very brave in this
performance i really gotta commend you
when you went for it
that is good did you like it and just
not respond or do the three dots and
then take it away
and then the three dots that's the
interesting that's the one
i i respect for trying very hard
consistently to
be positive about things which uh
especially people whose business is on
youtube
it's very easy to dip into being
negative because it gets more views
he's running a business he's employing
multiple people but still won't do it
greg's thing is being a champion and it
must be so tempting again as from a
business side to say negative stuff that
you know will traffic really well on
youtube but he doesn't do it and
yeah i respect all of them for that they
um they just shout about a kind of funny
shout about what they love
and aren't totally negative about the
things they don't love and
that's that's but they're also not
afraid to be passionate you know what i
mean it's it's not like they're just
kind of like
rose-tinted glasses you know blinders on
the fact that they've really devoted
their entire
uh social media presence right now to
uh the campaign and and not being
apologetic going we're taking a hard
stance
and this is what we think you should do
and we want you to know this is
important to us
the thing that i've always liked in this
now podcast by greg miller and kind of
funny
tim gettys especially if you ever need
to like
hey i'm not sure um like i i consider
myself an exhorter and a cheerleader and
someone who likes to encourage
um tim gettys is
one of the most inspiring
you will if you just have like a
15-minute conversation with tim gettys
he will make you feel like you can do
anything he will
and and start right now like not like
you know what i think we're gonna get
around to that you're like i need to get
off the phone with you right now so i
can go accomplish whatever it is that i
want to set out to do
um nick scarpino is one of the one of
the
favorite conversations that i had with
him is just him
being so insane that we were having
dinner in austin and him being so happy
was just like
this is what we've always dreamed about
doing we're finally doing it it's just
i the how community-minded they are um
what they've accomplished is incredible
and for all of those reasons
i'm out i just want to tell greg is this
like
hey man it's coming for you now man i do
like to say he is genuinely
bringing the performance andy cortez
more than any of them but i did also
want to mention uh annie cortez
awesome graphic designer and i am
planning to
yeah i'm planning to have him design and
i've already asked him it's just a
matter of like when he has time to do it
designer disagree with me baby shirt for
this show
specifically like i feel like andy
cortez could do a great job of that one
so i was gonna have him do that when we
get around to it very good i almost kind
of wearing
yeah it's good stuff uh but mike what i
wanted to ask uh to circle back to
video game coming out next week you've
sent out codes how do you decide who
gets a code well
oh that's a question and when that is
what's your embargo and how does all
that get planned
how does that all just happen so
actually that's the first thing is like
we haven't actually sent out codes
at the moment we've sent out embargo
offers okay so that's the thing i think
first off the people a lot of gamers
don't understand is
you know when you when you get critics
to review stuff you do an embargo and
there's lots of reasons to set an
embargo
you can do it very late if you're
worried that your game sucks you can do
very early if you're super confident
um yeah exciting
when i saw that there were no reviews up
already um and i didn't
get any any contact from them today i
think right
yeah they did and it was it's 8 out of
10 generally across the board so
good stuff excited to play for licensed
stuff
i'm really excited for that i have to
say as as a
as a die-hard x-wing tie fighter x-wing
versus tie fighter and x-wing alliance
player
uh this is a much needed overdue
return to that well austin what are you
doing friday night
um he's he's in a committed loving
relationship
that's true i don't know that we're
gonna see that's gonna depend on where
this uh
sentence goes because uh squadrons has
been very excited
yeah i'm i'm gonna be doing a
multiplayer stream with two of the
the devs so we could have a another i
could add another person if you have any
interest in joining me on friday night i
need to get a fan i need to get a
though like that's the biggest
limitation i have right now is
i won't be playing it with one initially
but how are you going to play it
control it that's how most people will
play it all mouse and keys
but controller is what they suggest is
there
is there cross play like because i for
sure that's a pc purchase
i'm definitely also playing on pc okay
so that's
all good across the board stop trying to
get out of it austin you could just play
a video game with me on friday night
i'm definitely not trying to get out of
it uh i am
definitely trying to look for the flaws
in the plan ahead of time and stuff
about you troy but i'm very glad to be
in the audience for this yeah
well you guys both hate star wars so you
guys just talking no
well i'm dressed as a jedi right now you
are back in the room anyway sorry to
circle back mike
oh no sorry though i wasn't i was just i
was just enjoying the awkwardness of
that conversation anyway amazing
um awkwardness and then the third no
awkwardness this is the only thing
no i didn't i was just gonna be british
we're hyper at what happens
there's a third reason to an embargo
which is if you have no marketing budget
is you want your embargo to hit as your
game does so that you can get as many
clicks on that review and if it's good
going into the site so indies often will
embargo for the exact moment the game
comes out
just because ultimately that's most of
our marketing on launch day is going to
be
you reading a review on a game's website
you like because we can't afford to buy
a banner so we want to have the review
hit
on the day and you don't want people to
have to wait three days to buy the thing
they can forget in three days
that's what i was exactly that's the big
one like we've done a lot of
work kind of promoting the wish listing
and and and it's worth saying actually
thanks to the audience of this show
because we definitely saw a bump when uh
when this podcast came out so thanks
everyone who did that
um because that helps in terms of the
run-up but in terms of like actually
selling copies of the game yeah you want
you want that review if the word is
going to be good about your game
you want the word to be happening at the
moment someone can actually come and you
know
bluntly give you money and and play the
game and especially
if you feel your game is good and i
think solitaire will see by the
you know by the next podcast we'll know
if it was good but like all our play
test data tells us this is one of our
better ones so we're kind of excited and
tentatively hoping that the reviews
would be good so therefore it's in our
best interest to have
i was gonna ask that next obviously
triple a's do mock reviews i know a
number of people who left games
journalism and started doing mock
reviews turns out there's quite a lot of
money and then actually you get paid
i asked someone once i asked like a
journalist once it's
really well paid oh yeah like but better
paid than media itself
um yeah exactly explain a mock review
you are
essentially in more detail than you
normally would for a long for a normal
review for games
but generally a lot longer um just
reviewing the game
as you always would have as media but
directly for the publisher so that they
can get an idea across the board of
using multiple of these mock reviewers
of what it will score and if there is
anything that they could possibly
change if you can give them an early
enough build or anything like that or
mark it around right
yeah what do you want to play like yeah
it's super interesting but is it also
is it buzz around does it ever manifest
the other way like
it turns out that this system uh really
sucks and is really hurting our score
and like
let's make sure to you know our
marketing was originally built around
you know our our our our
graphics just pulling a random thing but
like
we're getting dinged on that and so now
it's all about the story or whatever
specifically because of the feedback
because they're not they're too past the
point to be able to
shift gears on just the actual substance
of the game or
well the reality with mock reviews is
you usually are past the point where you
yeah
actually but i know that massive
specifically i know has done them
like alpha alpha alpha like they've done
one level when the rest of the levels
haven't even been made so they so
okay i have a question yeah um if i
said okay well let's go let's go review
this game all right
now there's it's only 40
done most of it's grayscale we haven't
actually put in this character yeah we
haven't recorded you're gonna be
listening to like
odd you know text-to-speech characters
but tell us what you think of our game
how does that help does that not hinder
you as as a as a developer going
ah [ __ ] this person from they hated the
text-to-speech just
magazines whatever it does they don't
they don't like grayscale
they don't like grey box version of the
game so why would they yeah the
the reality is honestly it depends on
your you always go into those things
with motivation you always go as
a developer knowing what the question is
you're trying to answer you don't just
go in and go is it good
because the team usually knows okay
like you're trying to figure out so yeah
so it's the same as play testing like
when i go and playtest a game i know
i'm not i don't care if the people play
testing the game like the game
that's it's nice to know if they do but
generally with play testing especially
early play testing
you're just trying to figure out okay
what are they getting stuck on what does
nobody understand
we put out our plates our first play
test on solitaire and
we had nobody understood one of our core
mechanics because we just never really
tutorialized it
and everyone was messaging back going
this game's really hard because of this
it's like there's literally like a
flashing button on the top right they
need to click
and they're not doing it because we
never told them to so you're looking for
those kind of things that's play testing
with the mock reviews stuff it tends to
be as has been said like more about like
what is going to be the thing that
people are going to be sharing
screenshots of what's the thing that
like reviewers are going to pull out
i don't know if this is the case and
troy you might actually know this but
like
with um the nemesis system in mordor my
presumption as a pla as a game dev
seeing the way they
presented and and did the final pr push
on the first game
was oh my god they did their mock
reviews and
their critics [ __ ] love the nemesis
system because in the game the nemesis
system
isn't showy it's not it doesn't feel
like that game exists just because of
nemesis system it feels like that was a
game that was lots of things
but the way that last three months of
promotion on the first game went
and how much it focused on the nemesis
system it felt like a doubling down it
was like and i think this is a fair
like i like that game a lot but it's
definitely a
solid to okay open world game
with this one glowing fascinating
mechanic that's really interesting
the worst familiar that's the word
that's the selling point and it felt
like that's what they were doing it felt
like that felt like a reaction to mock
reviews i have no idea if that was the
case but
so it's funny that you mentioned that
i've literally so with this badass new
pc that i've got
i've been there's so many games i got a
little bogged down and
like oh my god now what am i gonna play
and
the other night i was like i'm just
going to drop in
to get because it popped up on steam and
it was like 499 or 7.99 whatever with
shadow of war
you can get shadow mortar and shadow
award with all everything available for
like 10 bucks i was like i gonna do that
i want to see this thing on pc
so i just like dropped in and and
started playing it again the weakest
part of that game
is the story or the harder performance i
was gonna say it but you got there
austin faster hangs back with the
meanness like usually it's you or me
that it's first of all
but he went for it that time i respect
it the story
and everything is the weakest it gets in
the way
it is just the best thing about so their
entire marketing
was centered around orcs orcs
orcs orcs and doing this like
even for shadow of war it was this weird
live-action they did all this stuff with
orcs it was the corridor crew guys right
did like a live action trailer for that
but
yeah the second one right yeah i
remember and
they did like this kind of weird comic-y
gimmicky
slap-sticky you know thing with and it
was just like that's not what this is at
all and it was so
off-tone it was almost borderline dead
island
off tone of but but the inverse
of what the game was like well you just
kind of took the piss on our story which
by the way gets in the way and we didn't
we just needed to go go run around
in mordor go run around in nirn and
karnan and all these places that you've
read about
and just just see what happens it's the
most instantly satisfying gratifying
game that you can play it's just like
boom
it it's always fun it's got that arkham
assassin's creed super finely tuned
fighting mechanic
and it's super fun but you're absolutely
right
they didn't they were they were really
leaning on this is a
great open world lord of the rings game
lord of the rings lord of the rings lord
nobody nobody gives a [ __ ] about lord of
the rings what do they care about is
holy [ __ ] i can do whatever and i have
emergent gameplay
shift focus and they all of a sudden
like you said in the last three months
it was like
um make your own story and timing-wise
that feels like when they would have
done the mock reviews and that's why
my entire conjecture is that but it's
real and that's interesting and then the
other thing is obviously mock reviews
can tell you the problems so i've got a
horror story if you want to hear it
which is we did volume
um volume was a stealth game we really
shot in friday
we released it in 2015. um and it was it
was a good
you say again sorry that was five years
ago it was five years ago there was an
article about it today which was like
that game came out five years ago geez
um but the um it's it's a stealth game
it's kind of melchized vr missions but
like spun out in any way
but we we sent that out we didn't do
mock reviews because we didn't have
budget to do that and we still don't do
mock reviews we do a lot of play testing
we don't do mock reviews and we send out
to critics
critics i feel this is quite a big game
we sent out a couple of weeks before
launch
and obviously once you send it to
critics that's the game and ultimately
it's their job to
appraise that game and share with their
audience um but i got like emails from
like two or three of them going
mike you know that like your entire
kind of death state loop is completely
broken and
and massively cheesable so basically you
would get to these checkpoints
uh and they'd save your progress and you
could continue but basically you could
play the entirety of volume just running
forward through the space and not
engaging with the stealth at all you
could complete the game in like an hour
review version yeah and because the the
joke with game developers and i think
we're we're slightly more mature as a
studio now but
the joke with game developers is we play
our games right it takes players to play
and find all of these kind of things
that we never planned for because we're
always playing the game
quote unquote correctly and um and we
and and and we were obviously terrified
because basically
like we knew we knew we were gonna get
dinged in reviews for him we absolutely
did
but we also knew like we're gonna launch
with this so there was this kind of mad
dash
while the critics were playing the game
and reviewing it and if you go back and
read volume reviews a lot of them do
point out this massive game design
problem
and by launch we fixed it so when
players got in
we were there with a solution i think we
got it in like two or three days after
launch but it was this mad dash during
that reviewing process
to fix a fundamental problem in the game
design
um and it it sucks and it was a real
lesson for us because our
you know the metacritic on volume was
not as high as it could have been if
we'd gotten that right
um you know players that also increased
it was still it works as a long form
like the game sold well over its
lifetime but
damn was that bad launch and that was a
lot of lessons for us
doesn't that also create the problem
that also all the reviews are fl
like dinged the game for something that
the players then wouldn't
have found in the game sure but that's
right
that also no i know
and i feel like this is such an
interesting conversation is is the idea
of playing games wrong
if you chose to play it that way how can
you and you knew that you were playing
it the wrong way
how can you criticize it for that
because you're correct we the only issue
is we had leaderboards so there was a
competitive aspect
uh getting competitive yes i'm with you
on like a single player thing yeah if
you cheat in the game that's your
problem but like
you know there's a um we had people we
had journalists in the leaderboard like
we ended up deleting all this data but
we had journalists who were like
completing the game like in half an hour
yeah we really messed that up but we we
did fix it it was fine but yeah that's
why you do mock reviews is to find those
things
what do you think about doing mock
reviews or
um narrative tests early narrative tests
like uh
early early access you know or or even
you know
that would be i agree i don't do it for
narrative i'll do it for game play for
now there's a lot of people that do it
though
oh for sure the narrative test no way
look i know
everything i mean i don't play tests
like loads don't they
well they're doing there's no idea
people are just not getting this about
this story right now i'm like
yeah yeah because we haven't even gotten
into
acting that's why i don't do them that's
why i don't do them because i'm like
with
with narrative that's where i put on my
kind of artiste hat
and say well i'm i'm going to tell my
story how i want to tell it
with gameplay for me that's a
functionality issue with gameplay we
will play test and figure it out because
ultimately like if they can't play the
game they can't experience the game like
that's
testing whether we're succeeding but i
do understand like with narrative design
and especially on more complex games
than mine
i understand why you would want to do
that because you are telling stories in
very complex ways lots of different
moving parts
but possible it's
yes but if it's if you're telling your
story right
this is what i hate is always the result
i've never without any variation have i
seen
a difference where it's
uh people aren't really finding this
important so we need to double down on
this and make sure that the
player understands that this is
important and they're looking for the
key or that this person was really
and let's remind people that this
happened i'm like
no if if you have to remind somebody of
something
then if you like robert mckee talks
about this like flashbacks are the
biggest cheat
yeah and if you have to use a flashback
it's not a big deal i feel that way
about a news story
you tell me information via a news story
it's just a broadcast yeah like and this
happened and this happened and this
happened i'm like
but yeah all right writing's hard
sometimes
it's fine i just know i just wrote
something recently that has a news
reporter character in it
that's it's a great way to expose it it
is it's it's
it's an easy way amazing he's lazy
though he's lazy um
there's there's interesting way you're
like i have to onboard
the player into my story the character
of the world
and i can only do that i can do that
diegetically and i can
or i can do it in a non-diegetic way but
either way i'm going to employ some kind
of cheat
dialogue hitchcock even said is a cheat
like and when all else fails use
dialogue
so if you can set a tone and set a mood
without he could choose where the viewer
would look
exactly hitchcock had control of the
camera and that means he gets to say the
biggest thing i was going to say that
i've seen
in play testing like to use an example i
can talk about gunfire games
um i was talking to them about a ton of
their play testing stuff for
the darksider series because obviously
the darksiders games are very puzzle
heavy they have a lot of puzzles
and there are basically just instances
which as a player you wouldn't even
necessarily pay attention to
where there's something shining you know
what you have to open
but they also have to do a camera pan
and pull to the thing because enough
players just walked past it even though
it was shiny and movable
but enough people were like what where
do i go that they're like okay we
camera on that and the gears of war
franchise does the same thing it's the y
button it's like look exactly where you
need to look so i guess that's like
a default if you can't figure out how to
get players to look at something
even if you feel like you've made it
incredibly obvious it's just pulling it
i know i was gonna say naughty dog uh
the in in the last of us
yeah i always hear that thing and the
funny thing is i take it as an insult
when i'm exploring and then it's like
and it's telling me like
we think you're lost and i'm like [ __ ]
off i'm not lost i'm enjoying
your [ __ ] game frustrates me if
you're like okay i finally took a hint
give me a hint they're like maybe you
should look around i'm like [ __ ] you man
i give all right you broke me just like
explore a bit bro
you want to know a um the the movie
the movie industry i don't i don't know
if mock reviews are a thing but
obviously
um the uh like getting scored
test audiences is a thing and and it's
and composers are
notoriously on the crap end of that
because what happens is
you obviously can't show a rough cut
uh and expect to get any meaningful
feedback
from like an audience of of normies uh
in the same way that like a completely
broken build
will just yield noise it won't yield
actual feedback and so if you show a
thing that's
you know act one is twice as long as
it's supposed to be all the visual
effects are missing
even even like it's color graded and
it's not color graded so you can't even
see the thing in the background of the
shot that's supposed to be the
them and of course the music is not done
which depending on the filmmaker may or
may not
make it narratively broken so the the
thing that ends up happening though is
because they will
do focus testing late in the process
when the movie's basically done the
result is that almost always the only
real meaningful change they can make
at that point is the music and a number
of times composers have gotten screwed
over
because they're dice they're desperate
to do any kind of damage control they
can on their movie that's
underperforming in these focus tests
and so they just sort of yank the
composer around a very famous
in composer circles a famous example of
that uh 10 years ago so you remember
joe johnston like rocketeer joe
johnston's
wolfman movie with with anthony hopkins
that one had a disastrous
uh focus test uh pretty close to release
and danny elfman had been hired to do
the score and did a very elfman like
gothic horror kind of like you know his
sleepy hollow that he did for
tim burton and um and they were like
well obviously
it's not we want it to hit the you know
the young one i think this was
was this lion's gate or universe but
they were like we want this to hit with
the
you know oh yeah we want this to to hit
better with the you know the youngins so
they threw out elfman's score and
replaced him with paul hasslinger from
tangerine dream to do like
epic metal and then they screened it
that way and bear in mind all this is
happening like
you know two weeks later okay paul we
need the finished score of this entire
movie so it just
explodes out this score they focus test
it again and it's like cataclysmically
worse but they also re-cut a lot of [ __ ]
as part of the process it wasn't just
swap the music but
trim this move that around add those
shots remove those shots
and it also scores yard every line that
uh what's his name had
uh uh not anthony
yeah what i know is hereditary the
original
uh ending the story doesn't the story's
not the story's not over though that
here's the
here's the crazy thing so they've tossed
elfman
they've replaced him with uh paul
hasslinger who's done plenty of
movies um but they were like oh [ __ ]
this was
a total misread so then they uh called
elfman
back and said i guess we want to
reinstate your score but they had recut
the movie so heavily that he basically
had to rewrite it again
so they essentially had to hire him a
second time in order and then the
hilarious thing
is that it comes out and people were
like this is pretty good and the score
was
really well regarded and it was like
he's obviously a genius
yeah he's on his way i know what he's
doing but all of that was because of
focus testing
and um i mean i get the importance of it
like you know if i write something
i generally will give it to but i guess
even my point is like with the the
various i've written what
four short stories that i actually liked
this year and then 10 that are terrible
but i'll give them to people with
specific questions when are you doing
that
i generally do it at night uh before i
go to bed i'll just
type away i try to do as much in a
sitting as i can sometimes it's the
whole weekend and i just do one and i
just get it done just to
keep doing that basically but generally
when i'm asking people for feedback i'm
asking for pointed feedback i'm not
going just read this whole thing and
tell me what you think it's
is this character strong enough does
this make enough sense like
a very it's like having a hypothesis i'm
like i think this part is weak and i
need you to know what you think of it
i'm very pointed and that would be i
think the same thing or as a
film that's play testing view test is
just
anything yeah but it sounds like a focus
test in a play test
or uh like it's it's yeah you know right
yeah you like say you need you you're
testing hypotheses you're testing like
yeah you always go in whether or not you
tell the person who you're testing with
what your question is is still have a
question you make but you're still
pointing to it though you're also going
tell me does this relation do the
relationship between these two
characters does that really matter
well i do that but i guess what mike's
saying is that you don't have to do that
you would just wait to hear it but
you're still wondering about that thing
i think yeah yeah but the site but the
second that it's uh heisenberg's
uncertainty principle right the
the the manner of something is changed
by the very act of it being observed
like the second you go
and tell me if if the dog makes sense to
you like i didn't even
okay i'll be king in on the dog yeah the
dog was or you're automatically in the
position well generally what you would
do is you'd say
so tell me about which characters were
interesting to you and then if they
don't mention the dog you make a note of
that and then you ask about the dog
but the other thing that's really
interesting with play testing is is you
can't take any one of their words
that's the joke with play testing is is
the worst way to play test anything is
to ask someone what they think
yeah the best way to play test is to
watch them to observe that process
um and also to always think about their
what the pro or the
basically treat the uh disease not the
symptom so often like someone will do a
play test and they'll be like your
game's too easy
and you could immediately go well we're
just gonna make it harder then but
actually if you look at one of them
playing it's like
oh they didn't realize that this
mechanic was there so they couldn't
engage with this higher tier play
oh that that that enemy's buggy and we
need to like fix that problem because it
made everything much easier
that they were actually like really
struggling but they just didn't know
they were struggling because our health
meet bar isn't like
there's a million causes of any problem
so you're always trying to track the
symptoms but work your way back to what
the problem underlying those symptoms is
that's the
i think it's it's also like there's a
lot of developers that you know there's
webcams you know that that
as you're watching people to you know
play and it's like they're like
so fascinating yeah they're like that
part really didn't um
you know impact me that much like you
know you were crying
we have footage of you doing that yeah
there is something that i think uh
there's another example of like there's
no score there's
there's no special effects or anything
there's a famous story
um that that ended up yielding some of
the best feedback ever and that's when
lucas screened for spielberg and de
palma
um the first star wars and it was like
you know what do you guys think
and spielberg was quiet and de palma was
like i don't know you got a green guy
you got this bear you have this whole
world that you're trying it's like space
but i don't understand it's like you
need like this big
long scrolling prologue you know just to
let everybody know what's going on and
so that's where that whole thing came
from as brian de palma came up with like
georgia goes like wow well episode one
episode four
that's how we it's like ah you're son of
a [ __ ] you had to start from four not
one whatever
not to mention that he wanted it to he
wanted um
he wanted a very kind of buck rogers um
uh old-fashioned serial musical approach
2022.
goes but specifically with the score you
show its appears that's why you don't
just play tech
you do play tests with like normal
people but you also play test with
we had it on again on solitaire we i
sent it to a bunch of
other developers and and and one guy
wrote me basically like an eight-page
document
i like vitor i can say who he is because
he was good he wrote me an eight-page
document which basically started with
your tutorials in your games
consistently suck
uh this is this game demonstrates again
that
this is bad here's where the problems
are and
i would suggest you investigate doing
this business so we tore out the entire
tutorial system
play tested it again with a new tutorial
system based on his suggestions
and that's when the game became like
isn't it always interesting when the
right person like a single
single piece of feedback yeah we had the
same right we were getting good play
test data it was like yeah this is fine
it's a card game it's just salted
and then like the next batch of play
test day we got was i've been playing it
for four hours
you know it's like that switch was
amazing there's a story i have
and that's the people you need around
you that's true true friendship just
like i don't like it dude it's very good
yeah but i always think of it by the way
is one of the greatest themes that's
that's like a it's done in 12 8 time if
nothing else listen to the drums
on that dude it's that drummer is
getting
after it listen to the buck rogers theme
you'll know exactly what i'm talking
about it's like
that guy's alana will add it underneath
what we're what we're saying
[Music]
yeah what i was going to say is i always
think of i always think of play testing
as a function of averages like you need
a wide pool of people but yet it is
interesting
when a single voice like vitor can
really and there's there's a story i've
told um
a bunch of times that but the short
version was uh uh when we were working
on journey and my old college roommate
came to visit la and i said hey you want
to come see this thing i'm working on
and
we knew that the ending of the game
wasn't quite sticking the landing but
but but tgc was having a
hard time kind of zeroing in on where it
was losing people
um and i remember my my my roommate
uh billy came and sat it
in robin hunnicky's office and like we
closed him in there and
and he played through uh the game start
to finish well
while the team had like stand up or
something and um
and then at the spoiler at the end on
the mountain
when it like fades to white the build
crashed and just hung on a white screen
and he sat there
and then he came out with this like pale
look and he was like this is the most
amazing thing i've ever played he
thought we had made this super bold
choice and it was like
you know it was like oh [ __ ] and that's
where we realized like
it it reaches this emotional peak at
that moment and then from that point
forward was where it kind of
um sort of seemed to drift off course
and that single
such a funny way to learn that because
it broke it's crazy
yeah but yeah it's just like lucky and
that wasn't a scheduled play test like
they were doing regular scheduled uh at
sony santa monica with like what troy
was talking about with the camera facing
the player and everybody would watch
them and
take notes and ask and then they'd have
questionnaires after and all that and
then there's just one
casual oh it's so cool and i've done
playtesting for horror games twice
the two horror games and i did some for
um some of you make you feel very
vulnerable
well i'm terrible five people sitting in
the room next door watching you live
we're probably freaking out the whole
time it's great
i like that when i did one of my horror
play tests there were people watching me
live
and i was also i've done it with the
one-way mirror
yep and like i'm so scared of horror
games despite survivors
always listening to buck rogers right
now
it was such a weird experience though
because when you know you're being
watched you also act differently
so like it's just such a difficult thing
to do that's the heisenberg thing
yeah yeah that's why it's like um when
you hear
uh directors talk about actors being
aware of the camera
uh it's like you just naturally just
it's that uh paul rubin's in
in in uh people here though he's the way
that he does they know his cameras
like there's the camera it's a herman
beijing mr herman
which by the way roger clark's like
favorite movie we had him host one of
our movie screening things
and i was like all right dude what what
movie do you want to host he's i was
like
he's this you know incredibly well-read
intelligent erudite
tombstone just lean into it what's going
to be like citizen kane
like what's it going to be yeah or is it
going to be like you know yeah tombstone
or or blatant blazing saddles you know
great westerns
um silverado what's it gonna be 310 to
yuma
and he goes uh peewee's big adventure
have you seen it troy it's a fantastic
tim burton's directorial debut i was
like
you're serious right now it's like is
this like a pissed take we're gonna have
everybody sitting and watch this guy i
made you all watch it and just leave
and he was like walking through his like
notice the film war aspect of this it's
a little something about roger clark you
didn't know he's danny elfman's first
ever film score
danny elfin's first score and tim
burton's ever first uh directed movie
he goes from that to batman no
beetlejuice that to beetlejuice to
batman yeah it's like boop boop boop
it's crazy
yep yeah it's nuts uh austin i believe
you have to go are we on top i do
i have to go 11 o'clock i have to go
judge young composers
uh on their uh democrats awful you're
terrible you should stop doing that they
leave them alone
you're like in fairness i will have
i will have where the fender bender came
from yeah exactly
keeps hitting minus that's how he that's
how he shows his judgment
my background is is hades because there
was a chance we were maybe going to talk
about hades today
everyone's talking about hades it's
really good about that today
but i didn't realize that roguelike was
was because it was
um based on the like old rogue game
mm-hmm it's like you didn't know that i
did not know that i thought it was just
kind of rogue-like you know kind of like
oh you just made that he's uh he's a han
solo type
roguelike now we should totally talk
about it next time though because uh it
was a
freaking awesome experience uh did you
work on you
what did you score hades or no it's
darren corb as usual with supergiant but
they they um there was like this
discussion because of the
the pax concert that we did where we did
an orchestral reimagining of kind of the
best of
um from pyre uh transistor and
uh bastion it was like so good man
yeah we and they did this whole thing
and so then there was this discussion of
like
well we could do a you know like a vinyl
proper studio recording we could maybe
do it at abbey road and i said you know
you haven't finished hades
we're gonna be in abbey road with an
orchestra
surely something in hades could benefit
from that and he was like
actually i think so and so i was like
please let me let me uh work on that
with you that would be just such a joy
i'm such a fan of his
and we're such close friends for for
years now in fact the first time we ever
hung out for real was
after mythos troy when we all went to
with logan cunningham
we went to the diner until like 3 a.m in
new york
we went to a bar first and then we went
to the diner it was off of 9th
like 57th and 9th or something and we
just
those are good we broke bread good times
good times i miss new york i miss london
and i miss paris
yeah they're gone they're just gone now
so yeah i'm gonna run uh i'm going to
feel free to keep going
and uh but i'm going to disconnect and
the show isn't
for the show isn't the show without you
i was going to
couldn't possibly get us out of here
we'll see you next week everyone
punch my microphone